[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
it's twitter versus elon musk the social
media giant and spacex inventor will
face off in a coming trial and i grieve
for these senseless killings and i ache
for the scars that are left behind on
the victims and on our community
officials identify everyone involved in
a mass shooting at an indiana shopping
mall that left four dead including the
gunman but first the first witnesses are
called in the parkland school massacre
trial we were
just sitting kind of like sitting ducks
we had no way to protect ourselves no
way to stand up for ourselves survivors
and family members of victims are called
to testify i saw his body
not spasming but more like trying to
take his like final breaths
and then at that moment you know it
started getting more real lawn crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer florida
juries hear from survivors of the
parkland school shooting on day two of
the gunman's penalty phase trial
17 people were killed and 17 more
injured when a then 19 year old gunman
opened fire at marjory stoneman douglas
high school in 2018. in october of last
year the shooter pled guilty to 17
counts of murder and 17 more counts of
attempted murder which prompted his case
to head straight into the penalty phase
in what's expected to be a months-long
case a jury will decide whether the
shooter is sentenced to life in prison
or given the death penalty on tuesday
jurors heard from family members of
victims and survivors of the shooting
alexander doret was both as he was shot
by the gunman and survived but his
brother was shot and killed
while i was sitting there you know just
trying not to
think this is real thinking it's you
know fake
um
you know and then
just not trying to process you know
what's going on and then um while i'm
sitting there you know i have a couple
people around me
that are just you know
trying also not to you know freak out
and
then
i remember feeling trickling down the
back of my head and onto my chest
and then you know i touched the back of
my head and then my hand was all bloody
i saw
alec schachner
passed away
over his desk
kind of like half of his body
there was like a metal bar on the desk
and half of his body was off the bar and
the other half was like still kind of in
a seat
and
i saw a pile of blood like forming under
him
and i saw his body
not spasming but more like trying to
take his like final breaths
and then at that moment you know it
started getting more real
joining us today is legal analyst joe
richardson and co-host terry austin joe
photos of the massacre even our
producers had commented on this were
supposedly so graphic people in the
court had to leave but the jury must
stay and see it all what kind of impact
will that have on their decision
it's going to have an incredible impact
um
you add the the photos along with the
testimony that is very precise people
remember dates times they're really
taking you back to the moment
what happened and it comes together like
a puzzle to really color this incident
and so the photos are incredibly
incredibly graphic but the soundtrack of
the photos are the
testimony of the individuals and based
on that when you put that all together
it has a
devastating impact on this defendant's
prospects we'll see what they say but
the impact is there's no there's no
doubt that it's incredible yeah now now
that's going to be compiled because
terry some of the testimony from the
victims well i don't want to say
redundant because of the connotation but
very similar as there are many victims
do you think that similarity between
these testimonies is going to hurt the
prosecution's case
i don't think it's going to hurt them in
this case the first thing is you don't
want to alienate the jury but this is
important testimony there are 17 people
who died 17 people who were injured each
of them has a unique experience and it's
important to tell that story it's really
important for the families to be able to
listen to what's going on making sure
that that story has been told the judge
has already limited certain pieces of
evidence so for instance she hasn't
allowed duplicity as far as photos are
concerned maybe two three per victim but
she is limiting some of that so i think
that will help yeah and of course the
guilt phase is done in the penalty phase
it's both about finding the right number
but also a sense of catharsis for the
victims and the victims family so it
makes sense that there may be some
similarities because everyone's got to
be hurt
on update now on the deadly oxford high
school shooting several news sources
report the school district officials who
met with the accused shooter before the
massacre were quietly placed on leave
four people were killed and seven more
injured when a gunman opened fire in the
high school last november a then 15 year
old suspect was taken into custody he
now faces 24 charges including murder
and terrorism he's being tried as an
adult his parents jennifer and james
crumbly are also charged with
involuntary manslaughter multiple news
sources now report that the district's
dean of students and school counselor
met with the suspect before the shooting
spree and were later placed on
non-disciplinary administrative leave
the detroit news reports the faculty
members were placed on leave for one
month following the shooting two civil
lawsuits have been filed against the
school district for negligence a judge
recently ruled surveillance video from
the shooting would be released
still ahead on law and crime daily our
coverage continues in the parkland
schools shooters penalty phase trial
still ahead hear the gripping testimony
from one of the prosecution's first
witnesses
[Music]
welcome back continuing our coverage of
the parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial after opening statements for
presents in monday one of the first
prosecution witnesses to testify was a
student who survived the massacre she
described what happened when gunshots
rang out
tell us what happens after you go near
miss riovan's desk so
then we go over to the other side of the
classroom by her desk
and at this time he still hadn't shot
into our classroom at that point we were
just sitting kind of like sitting ducks
we had no way to protect ourselves no
way to stand up for ourselves
and um
once we were all kind of in over by the
door and away from the door that's when
he had shot into our classroom
um
he injured four people in my classroom
one of them
um
being fatal
and from there we just kind of sat and
waited until the police came and took us
out of the classroom and did you do
anything to record what was it what was
occurring
yes um
i'm not exactly sure why but my initial
instinct was to pick up my phone and
start recording
and so i did i took several videos of
what was happening
one of those videos was shown in court
members of the gallery and the witnesses
broke down in tears as it played we will
only play the audio but we do want to
warn you the following clip could be
disturbing to some viewers
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i'm sorry unfortunately i'm hearing this
for the first time like many of our
viewers are um
but terry
what was the most powerful piece of
testimony that you think will decide the
parkland shooter's life or fate based on
what you're seeing and hearing now
well i definitely think that that tape
will be part of the testimony that will
move these jurors listening and watching
those people getting shot and killed
before their very eyes i think is going
to help dictate what should happen to
the defendant here it's definitely cold
it's calculated we know from the
videotape he did before the incident
that it was premeditated he said he
wanted to do this so i definitely think
that the videos in this case are going
to help that jury decide whether or not
the defendant here serves life in prison
without parole or whether or not he gets
the death sentence it is a horrible
heinous atrocious crime which is one of
the aggravated factors yeah it's it's
hard to talk about this as a lawyer uh
especially when many of us are our
parents or myself expecting to be a
parent but joe um we're just starting
but with this testimony in the audio
recording do you think the jurors will
have already made up their mind before
the defense even does their opening
because they plan to do it when the
prosecution's case is over
they took a chance by not saying at the
very least at the beginning hey listen
we want you to stay focused we're not
saying that he didn't do it we're not
saying he's not responsible for it but
keep an open mind or making some kind of
presentation at the beginning they took
a chance in doing that and the chance
that they take is that we may be so far
down the road of aggregating factors
aggravating factors that their attempted
presentation on mitigation doesn't work
so uh the you would like to think they
haven't made up their mind but
thus far the prosecution is the only
side doing an event uh presentation and
so therefore uh you know the defense is
certainly going to be in trouble any way
you look at it yeah i think i mean i'm a
public defender in brooklyn from canada
probably the most liberal person you've
seen on this show but
even my and i don't support the death
penalty even my mind is
kind of but we'll see how this case
continues
switching now to celebrity news four
decades after he fled the country as a
fugitive rowan polanski's attorneys say
they're pushing for the director to be
sentenced in a 1977 sexual assault case
newly unsealed documents show a
california judge indicated he would go
back on a promise not to jail polanski
the documents that feature testimony
from a prosecutor made in 2010 explained
that the judge planned to break his
promise to free polanski this led to the
director fleeing the country in 1978 and
becoming a fugitive in 1977 a then 13
year old girl claimed polanski sexually
assaulted her while the pair were at
jack nicholson's home she said polanski
gave her a sedative then forced her to
have sex the girl later refused to
testify in court and polanski pled
guilty to unlawful sex with a minor
polanski's attorney say the unsealed
testimony points to conduct and request
a new judge on the case outside of los
angeles county the director's defense
also argues that under coven 19 protocol
polanski should be able to appear via
zoom from france instead of in person in
the united states
coming up on law and crime daily the
shooters identified after a mass
shooting at an indiana mall
plus elon musk and twitter twitter go
head to head in court could their
lawsuit soon be headed to trial
[Music]
welcome back attorneys for social media
giant twitter and billionaire elon musk
face off in court for the first time as
a judge rules a five-day trial will be
set for october
this comes after twitter filed suit
against the tesla ceo when musk
announced he was backing out of a deal
to purchase a social media platform musk
made the move in april to purchase
twitter for 44 billion dollars saying
the site was limiting free speech he
said he wanted to take the company
private arguing he would be able to grow
twitter and make it more politically
neutral musk and his lawyers say he's
decided to back out of the deal accusing
twitter of withholding information about
the number of spam and bot accounts on
the platform in the merger twitter and
moz cat agreed either would pay a one
billion dollar breakup fee if they were
responsible for the deal following
through
attorneys for twitter motioned to
expedite the legal process requesting a
four day trial in september moss team
opposed the motion pushing for a winter
2023 court date on tuesday a delaware
judge ruled in favor of twitter setting
aside five days in october of this year
for the trial
terry moss has a number of arguments but
let's focus on the bots
he knew there were bots maybe not the
number but he knew they were there he
even sold himself as the one that could
solve the problem so why and how is he
backing out of the deal because of these
bots
he's basically saying yes he knew about
the bots but he did not know it was so
many as far as that platform was
concerned and so he was misled he's
trying to say that twitter was hiding
something now i don't think it's the
strongest argument i think the same
argument could say for spam for instance
that he knew there was spam but he's
saying he did not know there was as much
spam as there was so it's more of a
reliance argument than anything else and
i think at this point based on what i've
heard he's not going to prevail yeah joe
what do you think the goal is for
twitter to actually have musk run the
company or strike a deal so this merger
doesn't hurt the company and they make a
little bit cash
in an irony uh he uh you know offered
all this money you know 20 per share
more than the company is actually worth
but he's a door number one you know
what's behind door number one who's
behind door number one where would it
actually take the company i bet that
they're up in the air about that and on
some level it may be just as good for
them to get the billion dollars uh you
know uh for him breaking up the deal
and still you know solidifying itself a
bit more and then going along its way
and being in a situation that's a little
bit less risky i mean if i can make a
billion dollars because of a breakup i
would make sense we'll see how it
continues a veteran hollywood producer
known for his work on the sitcom scrubs
is arrested in connection to a series of
sexual assaults
eric weinberg was arrested last week for
what investigators say was targeted
behavior they say he scoped out women in
their 20s and 30s while at public places
like a coffee shop or grocery store he
then pretended to be a photographer and
invited the women to his home for a
photo shoot after that he would sexually
assault them officials with the los
angeles police department say they are
seeking to identify additional victims
saying weinberg's scheme dates back to
the early 1990s weinberg was also booked
for sexual assault charges in 2012 and
2019 for his latest harass weinberg is
being held on more than three million
dollars bail
when we come back the deadly indiana
mall shooting what we know right now
about the gunman and the victims
involved
welcome back to law and crime daily the
defendant chooses not to testify ahead
of closing arguments in a colorado
double homicide trial as kevin dean
eastman faces murder charges in the
deaths of his ex-girlfriend and her new
love interest eastman is charged with
two counts of first-degree murder
tampering with a deceased human body and
tampering with physical evidence for
allegedly killing heather frank and
local musician stanley scott sessions on
separate days in february of 2020. frank
and eastman both had arrest warrants in
connection to sessions murder before
frank's body was found prosecutors say
eastman slit session's throat inside
frank's apartment and that eastman
fatally shot frank in the chest twice to
silence the only witness to sessions
killing they say he then hit her body
near a burn pile on the property of his
new employer investigators say eastman
burned session's body and was allegedly
preparing to burn frank's body when he
was arrested at a nearby gas station the
defense rested its case monday shortly
after the defendant told the judge he
wouldn't be testifying here closing
arguments from both the prosecution and
the defense ahead of the case being
handed off to the jury on the next
episode of law and crime daily
and in indiana officials have identified
those involved in a shooting at an
indianapolis area shopping mall it
happened on sunday evening in greenwood
indiana at greenwood park mall three
people were killed after a 20-year-old
shooter entered the mall with two rifles
a handgun and several magazines of
ammunition police say he entered the
mall and immediately went into the food
court bathroom where he stayed for an
hour his cell phone was later found in a
toilet in that bathroom the accused left
the bathroom and began shooting creating
a scene of chaos police say he fired 24
rounds into the food court area
officials say the gunman shot and killed
pedro pineda his wife rosa miran rivera
de pineda and 30 year old victor gomez
he also wounded a woman and a child
an armed bystander elijah dicken shot at
the gunman firing 10 rounds killing him
greenwood's police chief calls dickens
actions nothing short of heroic saying
many people would have died if not for a
responsible armed citizen that took
action very quickly local officials
spoke at a press conference monday
thanking dicken
i grieve for these senseless killings
and i ache for the scars that are left
behind on the victims and on our
community
we're very thankful
for a young 22 year old man
who stopped this violent act
this young man greenwood's good
samaritan acted within seconds stopping
the shooter and saving countless lives
our city our community and our state is
grateful
for his heroism in this situation
joe elijah dicken absolute hero no
questions asked no one's going to debate
that but in this shooting comes the
narrative that a good guy with a gun can
stop a bad guy with a gun how did that
fit into this story where three people
or three victims were killed and two
injured
yeah that's the problem we focus on the
fact that uh mr dickens did what he did
and we're all glad that he did so and so
he saved other lives but the work is in
having the discussion about what we can
do to avoid the three from potentially
having to die in similar circumstances
this culture of weaponry this easy
access uh easy acquisition of guns et
cetera um sure there are certain parties
that have become a narrative a political
narrative frankly that this is the way
to go uh but for every such case there
are also other cases where someone
mistakenly uh gets shot who was not the
bad guy and so how do you know which is
which it could have been confusing they
were lucky um and um but there's more
work to be done yeah and let me be clear
i do not blame dickens for those who are
dead or injured i think he did
everything he can but the question is
how do we prevent one death or one
injury terry what are we learning about
this shooter and are we seeing patterns
with him and any other mass shooters
you know there are so many patterns here
we saw that this shooter was well
prepared he had an automatic rifle he
had a pistol he had 100 rounds of
ammunition and we saw that there was no
previous violence with this individual
that's been the same in many of these
cases he was recently evicted and he did
quit his job so perhaps he did have some
mental issues before the shooting
alright joe terry thank you very much
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you